well the pandemic has changed our lives
in so many ways but today's safe nest
is reminding the community help is
available for those victims of domestic
violence
they have launched a new virtual tool in
hopes of helping victims move forward
so it can be what we refer to as a
triggering environment this is the
newest tool safe net's
ceo liz ortenberger says will help them
in the fight
against domestic violence a virtual
system to help victims with their
temporary protective order
family court logistically can be very
difficult for victims and survivors of
domestic violence for one it's a shared
waiting room
so you could potentially be waiting
there to testify for your tpo and your
batterer
could be right there in the same waiting
room with you so there's an opportunity
for intimidation
according to ortenberger their hotline
call volume is up by 150 percent
since the pandemic began the
organization's services for mental
physical and domestic violence continue
to help both women and children
we know there was at least one case
where a victim was doing her temporary
protection order
over the system virtually in her from
her home and the batter actually broke
in and began
abusing her during the trial day or
night safenet says
they are ready to listen and provide
support resources and education
to anyone in need but taking that first
step is crucial
the hotline is 702-646-4981
what we're able to do here is provide
that privacy
in the waiting room support for kids so
that if mom or dad's coming in to file
that tpo the children don't have to
listen to the hearing
and we provide a more comfortable
environment to be able to do that